Temari Boris Johnson's can to try and
push through his plans for an early
election in December
how will you be voting I should be
voting against it this is not the time
to be holding a general election it's a
time for cool heads and grown-up
government Parliament has indicated
clearly that it is willing to support
this deal Prime Minister said he wants
the deal these deadlines 31st of October
are meaningless
the key thing now is to get the deal
properly scrutinized in Parliament that
doesn't mean delaying it by months it
means giving Parliament a few days a
couple of weeks to scrutinize the bill
amend it if necessary and then we can
make progress and the government should
stop making threats stop throwing
tantrums and get on with the grown-up
business of doing its business just
because he can't get exactly what it
wants doesn't mean that it should stop
working you say it's a time for grown-up
government I assume you don't think
that's what we have right now then
well this approach of you know the
government will say what it wants and if
it doesn't get it it will simply stop it
won't it won't engage with the reality
is not grown-up Parliament if the
government doesn't have a majority in
parliament and any government owes its
legitimacy to Parliament and it has to
trim to the clearly expressed will of
parliament now Parliament has made it
clear that it will support the Prime
Minister's deal but of course there will
be amendments that will be moved during
the course of the consideration the bill
some of them will simply improve
Parliament's control of the next stage
of the process some of them will be much
more challenging for the government and
and some of them the government would
feel very strongly opposed to but that's
not a reason for not considering them
I'm interested to know your views on
some of the amendments that might be
attached to the legislation and but just
to kind of finish off on the election
business I assume that you won't be
backing the Lib Dem an SNP call to try
and get an election by December the 9th
either it's the same the same point
you've got to solve the brexit problem
and then
of course we will have to have a general
election don't you course and when we do
have an election are you still hoping to
stand as a conservative candidate well
at the moment that's not possible
because I don't have the conservative
whip and I am NOT going to change what I
say and what I believe and what I think
about what is important for Britain's
future in any kind of attempt to sort of
sneak back in and curry favor with the
conservative leadership I hope that the
party leadership would recognize in due
course that abandoning the concept of a
broadchurch conservative party that
embraces people that have a wide range
of views abandoning that would be
electorally very damaging but I'm not
holding my breath
would you run as an independent then if
you aren't offered a way back into the
party that's my intention yes okay now
let's talk about the bill because it's
pretty clear that you want to get that
withdrawal agreement bill back on the
table really scrutinize it but would you
vote for it and continue to vote for it
as it currently stands no I think that I
voted for it at second reading
we now need a sensible timetable motion
so we have let's say four days to
scrutinize it in the Commons in
committee by the way if the government
had pressed on with this last week we
could virtually have completed that
process by now I I want to see
parliamentary oversight of the next
stage of negotiation strengthened
because let's be very clear the
so-called deal that Boris has presented
represents a final solution only for 2%
of the UK's population the 2% that live
in Northern Ireland for the other 98%
will be left dangling not knowing
whether we're going to end up with a
real deal with the European Union or
whether we're going to effectively be in
a no deal situation at the end of 2020
that's just more uncertainty for
business and for people as they go about
their day-to-day affairs so what we need
to do is strengthen parliamentary
control of the process now that's not a
guarantee of anything of course the next
Parliament may have a clear majority for
a hard brexit in which case that's what
it
will pursue that's how democracy works
but we can at least ensure that
Parliament not the government has
control of that process I mean there's
likely to be several amendments to the
bill and not least one for a second
referendum I remember and the last time
that I interviewed you and what you said
yeah a second reference it's a credible
action yes you said it's a perfectly
coherent position many people will be
strongly opposed to it but it is a
coherent position it deserves to be
considered so would you back an
amendment for a second referendum
probably not so saying that it's a
coherent proposition it deserves to be
considered is not the same as saying I
would back it I have long said that the
only way we're going to solve the crisis
in our society and our politics that
brexit has created is by a compromise a
deal which represents a bit of
give-and-take between the leave and the
remain sides of the argument a
referendum just asks the question again
between two binary outcomes and even if
the numbers move will leave a very large
proportion of the population feeling
that they've lost out and don't have a
stake in Britain's future so I don't
think repeating the question is the
right way forward I think a compromise
deal is the right way forward and could
that include a customs union for example
that's another amendment that could very
well be put would that be the kind of
compromise that you could support yes I
could support a customs union customs
union would overcome the problem that
this the there are two problems at the
center of this deal the first one is
that it splits Northern Ireland from the
rest of the United Kingdom if the whole
of the United Kingdom was in a customs
union then the whole of the United
Kingdom would be treated the same and
the threat to the Union with Northern
Ireland would be gone and the second big
challenge with this deal is that it
clearly could be a route to a no deal
exit at the end of 2020 and we've got to
rule that out people like me have been
saying from the very beginning what what
we're focused on is making sure that we
avoid a No Deal exit and that applies as
much to a No Deal exit in December 2020
as it does to a No Deal exit in October
to
19 at the same time their union many of
our viewers listening to this would be
like we always hear this woman piece
they just want to stop no deal but at
the same time what MPs are trying to do
is to just Borg everything down to be in
this brexit purgatory until bricks that
just doesn't happen at all I mean we've
just missed successive deadlines and MPs
have to take some responsibility for
this as well don't they well the
deadline the so-called deadline next
Thursday as Nicky Morgan has just said
wasn't decided by anybody in the UK
wasn't voted on here it was imposed by
the European Union is a totally
arbitrary date of course we've got to
get this resolved now as soon as we
possibly can and we need to resolve it
by a deal which takes us out of the
European Union so that we're done with
membership of the Union and that's a big
win for those that want to leave the
European Union but a deal that also
ensures that our economy will remain
closely aligned with our biggest market
and our biggest customer and that is a
win of sorts for those who wanted to
remain so that we can go forward with
some kind of compromise that allows this
country to come back together and be a
success in the future
you just said that the 31st is an
arbitrary deadline it looks like we are
staring another extension in the face I
mean you of course have had
conversations with many people you know
in the in Brussels what's your sense
about how long that extension could be
what we mandated the Prime Minister to
ask for a three-month extension to the
31st of January and we did that on the
basis of our best assessment of what was
the right balance between views at home
and views in Europe about what an
extension could look like
I think 31st of January is the is the
right answer and probably the answer
that the European Union will give but
I'm sure they will make it very clear
that if we get a deal done and ratified
before then even if we get a deal done
in November then that extension can be
brought to an end very quickly possibly
within days so that you know an end of
November exit is a perfectly feasible
proposition if the government just stops
messing about tables a sensible
timetable tomorrow for consideration of
the bill
timetable that would give us perhaps a
week or so in the Commons and then the
House of Lords will need a couple of
weeks and and then we can get this done
you say the government's messing about
but I just wonder if actually Boris
Johnson deserves a little bit more
credit than some people are giving him I
mean many people said he would never
going to be able to negotiate a brexit
deal in the time and yet he has he's
come back with a deal he's got it closer
than Teresa may ever did to getting
majority in the House of Commons surely
it's now time for you to step back and
say fair enough I underestimated you
well I've never underestimated Boris his
skill as a political operator and I've
said that consistently that he may be
able to do things that his predecessor
was unable to do because he's a very
slick political operator but the deal
that Boris has done is a deal that was
available to Theresa May 15 months ago a
deal that would have split Northern
Ireland from the rest of the UK Theresa
May rejected that Boris agreed with her
at the time that that was not something
any British Prime Minister could agree
he said as recently as September the
11th that a Northern Ireland only
backstop would be completely
unacceptable to the UK so pivoting to
accept something that's previously been
on offer from the EU it was their
preferred solution and has been rejected
because it didn't work for the UK is an
achievement maybe but a limited
achievement I think so he's put that on
the table now and people will want to
look very carefully at the detail of how
it works but Parliament has clearly
signaled that it is willing to get to
work on this bill so does this deal
damage the Union potentially it does I
say potentially because if the UK has a
very close relationship with the EU at
quote a free tariff free-trade alignment
of regulations for example then that
means that trade between Great Britain
and Northern Ireland will flow freely
and without any interruptions and any
duplications but if we have a different
relationship a WTO relationship with the
EU then there will be a hard border
between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and that would be extremely
damaging to the Union
just finally could have in the past I
think people saw you as a bit of a
classic conservative yeah you're a
skeptic Chancellor former Foreign
Secretary and now you have morphed into
a rebel so I just trying to work out how
are you finding life now is it kind of
troublesome backbencher well I haven't
changed my position what's happened is
that the government that that I
desperately want to support has changed
its view and is now presenting a deal
which could head to a No Deal WTO
outcome at the end of 2020 and that's
something I am very clear we must avoid
for the sake of our economy and for the
sake of the United Kingdom so I will do
what I have to do and say what I have to
say it's not a comfortable position I'm
not a natural rebel I want to be a part
of the conservative family a party I've
belonged to for 45 years and and and I
would very much hope but Conservative
Party does eventually decide that it
wants to remain a broad church and it
wants to have space for people with my
views as well as people with Ian Duncan
Smith's views within the same party